[Music]
hello everyone my name is GM Josh Brito
and I'm doing a lecture on submitted
games if you'd like to have your games
analyzed and critiqued and yelled about
in this lecture you should email them to
what's the dress info info at st. Louis
chess club's a comma and then or.org
sorry and you can do it and submit it
through the YouTube channel so today I
last week what I did was I went over
sort of segments of games I didn't go
over a complete games I went over
certain parts of different different
member games and said in this situation
I would do this today I wanted to switch
it up a little bit and actually go over
a whole game which was submitted by a
member named John Morman the reason I
chose this game first of all that he
annotated it himself a little bit and he
also had some funny comments usually
self-deprecating which I always can
relate to myself so I thought that it
was kind of it would be kind of nice to
go over this whole game and I'm going to
kind of give you a grandmaster
perspective on problems that a club
player will face during a game so to
give you a situational thing this was
played at a local club I do not know the
time control but apparently there was no
time control I should read before I talk
and just the casual game uh John was
black and what apparently was out rated
by 500 points so facing an uphill battle
already with the black pieces against a
higher rated foe but let's take let's
kind of look at the game through John's
perspective and see if we can come up
with improvements on his play see what
he did well see what he didn't do well
and hopefully we can kind of learn from
these mistakes and it can maybe help in
your
games efore c5 big blunder already John
just kidding Bishop c4 so you guys
probably know that most people in this
situation there are lots of different
lines you could play c3 Sicilian you
could play Grand Prix attack with either
F 493 f4 you can play close Sicilian
type positions with G through Bishop g2
or open Sicilian which would go Knight
f3 for example d6 one of many options
there's a check as well the real salimos
and you get open Sicilian and tons of
different variations I'm sure most of
you guys know this already but how do
you deal with a move like Bishop c4
let's say you may have seen this move
before of course it can't be a terrible
move right attacking the center putting
getting a piece out I mean how bad can
it possibly be so the question I have
kind of for you guys is how would you
how would you respond to a move like
this like what do you feel about it um
and kind of how do you handle a
situation where say you're out of book
already I moved to or out of book early
or at least not in familiar territory
super early in the game yes
very well said ecigs is a nice looking
move here which loves the diagonal the
bishop and and also prepares for d5 so I
like this kind of thing a lot and again
I would say one of the most important
things is that often when people
especially Club players I find face move
they're not familiar with they make the
assumption that they're bad I think this
is a big mistake because if you assume
that the move is bad and it's perfectly
fine you're going to try to punish it
unjustly and you'll find but often
you're unsuccessful because you know the
moves just not that bad Bishop c4 may
not be a main move here it can't be that
bad it's just impossible so you have to
realize that while this might not be the
best move to fight for advantage maybe
it's not a terrible move and you
shouldn't go crazy trying to trying to
punish it but I like ecigs just the same
in the game d6 was played which i think
is a perfectly fine move nothing wrong
with it it doesn't blunt the bishop
right away but it can
the pawns in the center prepares to get
out the bishop in some positions doesn't
hang anything and I prefer not to hang
pieces most of the time so so far so
good
white played Knight f3 and here John
mentions that h6 prevents Knight g5 but
that the further delays development and
would have avoided a non-existent threat
anyway and I have to say that I agree
with John's assessment that this move is
unnecessary as far as moves like h6 go I
would say that almost always you won't
want to play these moves unless there's
a direct threat which John correctly
points out and you don't want to be
scared of ghosts in the opening you can
end up playing moves like h6 and it's
not necessarily some awful move but if
you play too many unnecessary moves
you'll find yourself a little bit behind
the development or committed to moves
which you maybe don't want to be
committed towards so you want to avoid
moves like this unless they're
absolutely necessary and you can
actually get yourself into more trouble
than simply developing and playing
normal moves by trying to be overly
cautious so I like John's move better of
96 you could have also played east 6
John if you are really concerned with 95
but again I think it's nothing
nevertheless white plays the move Knight
g5 so let's see what my extremely strong
audience has to say about this move yep
ecigs and 95 of the two moves you
consider you don't want to put your
night on the edge of the board I assume
and your direct and your definitely want
to deal with this threat what do you
think of the move Knight chief s you
think it's a waste of time why is that
absolutely moves like this are almost
always just not a good idea unless you
have a concrete threat that can't be
easily parried in this case you're
attacking that seven pawn good for you
but when black defends is you're not
good on g5 I don't think so so I think
that moves like this almost o is a
mistake what John says is that even
though this is my first time playing my
opponent he senses I'm a beginner and
therefore tries to beat him with a move
like Knight g5 I think this is just a
terrible approach because even if your
opponent falls for it so what okay you
won the game a little easier if they
were going to fall for this and you're a
much stronger player you'd probably beat
them anyway you know but if they defend
against this threat and they play good
chess then you can find yourself in a
lost position against an opponent who
you should be beating so I would say
that avoid moves like this if at all
cost
now another question you mentioned 95
and e six I really prefer one of these
moves over the other interesting I
actually prefer a six I want to hear
your logic of 95
aha so you so your point is that 95 is a
temple move hitting the bishop which
means that it should be preferred over
east six which while a temple move you
can play d3 and defend the knight
I actually don't like this logic and let
me tell you why the way I would think
about it is that ISA 'kx is the move I
know I want to play for sure so e 6 is
not only a temple move but it's an
improving move for me I don't
necessarily want my knight on e5 I think
that's a nice actually very nice on c6
and if I go to e5 I give the options say
of playing Bishop e5 check which is
obviously a temple move in response and
I'm not going to sure my name's good
here maybe white will play f4 and kick
it away so I actually much prefer a six
and in fact that's what Jon chooses so I
think this is the best move however
clearly Jon had to be a little bit pay
attention a little bit more not only to
his opponent's ideas but to his own
because white played a very poor move
here so the question is why is Queen f3
such a poor move yes it does so this is
something that looks really basic like
how can you not take a hanging Knight
well John we've all been there before
what happens is you get so carried away
with your opponent's idea you forget
that you have moves to that you have
ideas hopes and dreams of your own
and in this case Queen takes Knight not
perish the threat of Queen takes f7 and
takes a knife so it can't really be
argued with and again you can only logic
so much when it's basically piece hang
that you don't do but I bet you if this
were just some normal position you would
have taken this knight immediately the
reason why this wasn't played is because
you are so fixated perhaps on this pawn
being attacked you forgot that you're
also attacking the knight so you have to
keep track of not only your opponent's
threat and what they're doing but all of
your tempo moves and possible captures
because Queen takes Knight takes care of
this threat very handily and obviously
takes a three piece but of course there
are moments like this in lots of games
ninety five would be maybe another move
to consider
but after Bishop e5 check you're not
going to win anything so I prefer taking
the knight for free I like three pieces
it's one of my character flaws so Knight
f6 was played which does prevent Queen
takes f7 mate so it's certainly not the
worst move on the board but obviously
the free Knight would have been very
tasty so white plays castles which is
given a question mark by John because
the knight really doesn't have no nice
retreat squares and would have to go to
h3 I would say question marks a little
bit harsh John the reason why is because
if you play queen III you're also
wasting another move so black might
develop and capsule and it's just too
much time like whites already wasted
enough time to be perfectly honest that
being said the fact that this might
could end up on h3 is a pretty sad thing
but I think White's already in trouble
despite the fact you didn't take this
piece you still have an excellent
position everything centralized I like
every single one of these pieces and
pawns whereas these pieces look kind of
ridiculous now that f7 mono weakness so
you played aged six Knight age three
there should be seven here you chose to
continue development while White's
pieces are out of the game I think this
is an excellent approach white played d3
and you played 90 for threatening
several forks and forcing the Queen back
to d1 to defend the c2 square now I'm
curious what our audience our esteemed
audience thinks of this move
aha
I agree with all of what you said except
I would not play a 94 even after
Catholic and this is my reasoning
so 94 hits the queen and forces it back
threatening several forks I think is a
little bit optimistic John I have to say
your threat it's one fork and then the
Queen easily goes back why I don't like
this move is because when the Queen goes
back to d1 your knight is now not really
that well place it hits this pawn that's
wonderful but next move White's going to
play c3 on you and maybe you could try
b5 and try to go after this Bishop but
honestly I don't really like moves like
this unless you have a concrete follow
up like if you thought b5 and winning
trying to go after this Bishop was
really strong for you I kind of
understand but to be honest I like the
Queen better on d1 than on f3 the clear
on f3 is vulnerable 295 attacks
sometimes 94 can be an attacking move it
doesn't really it just doesn't really
want to be here so forcing the Queen
back actually improves the Queen at
least in my opinion and does not improve
your Knight and this is the kind of move
I see from I'd say Club players all the
time and I think that if you can get it
out of your system you're going to play
much better chess overall what this type
of move is it's basically you look for
tempo moves which you always should and
in that temple move of course being any
capture and a check any threats these
are the move that come first so 95 94
all moves to consider but if a tempo
move doesn't lead anywhere you have to
be able to let it go just say I don't
really want to attack your Queen it
doesn't do anything
95 incidentally would make more sense
just because it hits the bishop but of
course there's Bishop b5 chick so you
don't actually get to take this Bishop
for a knight which would be a nice trade
admit so I would have just canceled here
now with a castles saves 94 for a rainy
day maybe 95 comes back saving this
Bishop by the way is actually not so
easy now
for example if the bishop comes back you
can play Knight d4 and take it if you're
so inclined to be honest I'm not so
thrilled about even taking this Bishop
because it looks like a bad piece to me
hitting that biting on granite on e6
but let's say C 3s plate you have the
option of 95 now and taking this Bishop
and this position just looks extremely
Pleasant yes these double ponds may not
be that bad but looks like a pretty good
position to me so I would have preferred
castles but you played 94 not a horrible
move by any means but again I feeling
this can be a slight waste of time
so queen d1 and you castle so you wrote
I felt like I had the upper hand around
this time given that white tonight on h3
is awful and moved twice and white lost
to Tempe moving the Queen unfortunately
fortunately for my opponent I am I am a
beginner so I liked your sense of humor
John ah the only thing I would correct
is that first of all does Knights move
three times and while you claim that
White's lost temp temp tea with the
Queen if you play see if white plays c3
and you move back you've lost Tempe with
your knight so I'd say that you have to
be objective as far as who's lost 10:10
p.m. with which moves so your knight
move kind of costs you a little bit here
you could have tried b5 and going after
the bishop to at least justify this move
but again I don't think taking this
bishop is some huge achievement just
because again it's biting on granite
it's not doing anything but okay Knight
c3 dubious I thought my knight was going
to be kicked by his pawn and you were in
fact correct c3 would have been a better
move you could try b5 but I think you
lose a pawn after simply pawn takes
Knight and takes maybe you can take here
actually but again I don't see any real
need to to go for this it looks a little
bit weird to me
but yeah then I would come back and you
would have lost the temple 93 doesn't
really punish your Knight d4 move
because now your knight looks a little
bit more reasonable also I've mentioned
that this bishop might lack retreat
squares on some positions so you played
b5 and this move I think is fairly poor
the reason being very simple that I
think white can just capture this pawn I
don't really see a reason not to you you
gave this line rook b8 and stopped here
but really I think if the bishop just
moves back so
where you haven't really gained enough
for your pond your rooks on an open file
but my bishop can shut it down very
easily this pawn is not even a weakness
it's defended by the bishop it can't be
attacked so it seems like you just lost
a pawn for no reason you have to be very
careful about you know making kind of
unprepared like making pawn thrusts when
you're not prepared to defend these
pawns I didn't much prefer to move like
d5 so first of all if the bishop moves
back you can always take it and
extricate your night if you want you
don't have to take this bishop but you
can and taking this pond will be
ill-advised perhaps an audience member
can tell me why or perhaps not all right
because you recapture the bishop would
have to move anyway and now you can
shatter White's King side with a move
like Bishop takes fh3 Queen d7 Queen
takes here and I think White's going to
be crying rather soon and certainly
regretting this whole night escapade in
the opening so white probably should not
take but nevertheless I think a move
like d5 hitting the bishop putting it on
a square can be captured it's a very
nice improving move for you so I would
have considered this move instead you
played d5 your opponent for whatever
reason didn't feel like taking a free
pawn it's always nice when this happens
you played a5 going after the bishop I
can't say I dislike this move white
plays a3 but I don't really care for a4
can anyone in the audience which is now
grown by one person perhaps tell me why
or do you agree with John's move do you
think that a four is a good move you
don't agree with it so why do you why
would you prefer not to play it for
exactly so while you well it looks like
these pawn moves are nice they're not
necessarily achieving that much for
example if you play b4 and I go back
here I don't think you've achieved that
much b3 you're not defended enough times
really to support this if you take and I
take you haven't gained anything and
this bishop is actually a little bit
safer on a2 than it was on b3 to be
honest because I like your position so
much for simplicity's sake I probably
would have just taken this bishop off
the board and now notice how because of
a3 white has to compromise their pawn
structure a little bit more always a
good thing and again you have plenty of
choices but I like the very simple efile
now note how there's no bishop that
you've now that you to activate is
happen in the game which we'll get to
but this Knight is now under attack and
how do you defend that guy probably you
have to play Queen f3 but this is a bit
of an unfortunate move because the Queen
might end up on a bad square I would
even consider attacking the Queen and
playing b4 note how he too is taken away
and the anti you looks defended exactly
so in a position like this I think that
you should be fairly happy I guess
there's ninety five you have to contend
with so maybe there are some tactical
reasons not to do that but even if you
end up giving up your bishop and just
coming back look at these pot look at
this pawn structure it's just really
terrible again maybe you could do better
than this I didn't care for giving up
the bishop i but I was just kind of
giving an example of how a move like
Queen f3 can be lead to trouble and
again you could also play just a very
simple move like vision b6 which I like
more because now you hit this weak pump
and do you really want to play Queen
back to d1 I highly doubt it so I think
this is just a great position for you
so you kind of missed an opportunity and
again notice how simple it is you just
take away a bishop play e5 hitting the
knight taking away the f4 square so then
I can't get back into the game and it's
just very simple and you'd have an
excellent position as is you played a
four what you get isn't a blunder or
anything like that but now this bishops
a little better and your next move I
strongly dislike I'm kidding it's not
this move you play Bishop d7 which i
think is perfectly fine
again you could play e5 but I don't like
it so much when because now you've given
new life to this Bishop this Bishop
which basically was biting on granite as
mentioned now is a lot more open so yes
you might take this Knight and ruin the
pawn structure but even if white plays
the move like f4 this pawn structure
ruin isn't that big of a deal if my
Queen can kind of get over here to
defend my pawns and also note how now
this bishop is just a monster because
there's no way to dull it with a pawn so
for example if you try to play Queen d7
I play f5 play Knight d5 you could end
up under big attack for nothing very
quickly so this is actually how you get
into trouble from a good position so I
only recommend a5 if you are able to
snag this visual you played Bishop e7
which is a developing move it cannot be
bad this should a three and this is
where so you played rook c8 I don't know
I mean I would probably play something a
bit more direct like just defending this
pawn even a move like Queen b6 for
example but rook c8 you give it a
dubious I don't think it's that bad but
probably wouldn't be my move I'd
probably play something like Queen b6
this mentions Knight f4 was played so
White's trying to get the knight back to
the game understandably and this is
where you play e5 which you correctly
label as a mistake because you've opened
up the diagonal for the bishop so this
kind of mistake usually comes from not
being positionally aware so what i mean
by that is because you're kind of
looking for temple moves you're trying
to support your knight if you look at it
from this particular perspective a5
makes perfect sense and we've all played
moves like this for sure but you have to
look at the whole board
it's easy to forget about this bishop
because right now is doing nothing but
the second you forget about it and move
your pawn you've activated it and make
it a strong piece
not to mention weakening a key square
which now this Knight can hop into so
really with one move you kind of destroy
what your positions about notice how
white doesn't really have any threats
here if you just play Queen b6 I mean
what exactly is y going to do trying to
be super agro and take everything is
just bound for failure I can even take
this Knight if I want but even if I just
play like this there's no way in a
middle game position the rook and pawns
are worth the two pieces in the middle
game the two pieces almost always will
slaughter the row components just
something I know from experience there
are exceptions but right now all white
has to do is activate the pieces maybe
target this pawn once this Bishop gets
open White's going to be toast toasted
so really there was no reason to panic
or do anything crazy Queen b6 and you
still have a beautiful position but you
play d5 whether it was not a panic or
just forgetting about this Bishop I
don't know but I would say that this
really costs you quite a bit so 95 would
have been a very simple move but this is
also kind of annoying again easy to
forget about moves like this but once
you open this that's kind of what can
happen to be perfectly honest though I'm
not so sure taking this bishop is some
kind of huge achievement because if you
take this Bishop would you say this is a
good Bishop so on the same colors all
the pawns right this is definitely the
better Bishop whereas if you play 95
just to show you
you're no way obligated to take this
Bishop you're nice because it's going to
sit here right so for example if you
play Knight takes Knight takes you just
have a beautiful night now probably
black should try to play Bishop g5 to
trade off the bishop but even a move
like f4 is possible and again I'd say
that whites White's taking the upper
hand because what black will have a
weakness here and again beautiful
beautiful bishop and you do not want
your opponent's pieces
to be beautiful I know that sounds like
real piece of wisdom now but I would say
it's generally true so in a g6 c4 so
here I think you may be panicked a
little bit John again panic is one of
the leading causes of deaths and chest
positions the reason why is because if
you miss something there are two
possible reactions that people do in
both are mistakes one is they either
don't leave and they just brush it off
me they're like alright I missed
something time to just play on the
problem with this is that if you miss a
move and I'm sure ninety six was missed
as most of us would miss it you there's
a tendency to kind of go oh I you know I
missed a move alright let's just you
know move on and keep playing chess the
problem is if you missed a move you're
not seeing the position clearly you're
not seeing what's going on in the whole
position and when you do that you have
to reset kind of refocus and be like
alright what's going on in this position
now my rooks attacked so I don't want to
allow a knight takes rook and the
bishops attack but that's not a big deal
there's no mate threat so that I can see
maybe I'm missing them but I don't see
them so if you play just simply rook e8
why probably gonna have to take this
Bishop and that's not such a big deal so
the key is to stop and refocus the other
problem that sometimes people have is
the opposite reaction they miss a move
and they just freak out they just go oh
my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness time to go crazy and this is
obviously also not a very good thing to
do
it sounds like I'm exaggerating but some
people have this reaction and the key is
to have neither to respond in a calm way
but almost never do you want to blitz
out your move immediately after missing
something and you also don't want to
panic and oftentimes when you panic you
find some move which is completely
irrational like to me c4 is not
irrational because you're trying to shut
down the bishop but you're not seeing
the position clearly if you miss that
your rooks attacks right if you had
played the calm rook e8 the game
continued and again nothing horrible
happens nope there's no fire nothing
horrible just you play on but after c4
and you drop your rook
now you're simply done in exchange
pretty much for nothing this bishop sort
of shut down but at the same time it can
probably get open later and you're
simply down too much material so after
Bishop takes Knight I don't even know if
I would take this Knight I mean pawn
takes pawn looks fairly simple but
taking the knight also has its pluses so
it takes yeah Knight takes d5 yeah
you're just losing too many pawns and
again this night leaves a little bit
vulnerable so maybe this would be a hope
but I'm not so sure you can actually win
it Queen b6 yeah taking out d4 is quite
bad so it takes on c4 d5 I don't know
about but I mean even if you just take
on e4 maybe you have a little counter
play but ultimately you're just down way
too much just pawns a little loose
you're down in exchange you've lost some
pawns it's just hard to recover from
something like this your opponent
decided not to relieve you of your b5
pawn though at the same time it's still
very difficult to do very much
you played Queen b6 which is a logical
move and again maybe they should have
thought about taking your pawn in order
to take the d4 pawn so for example here
Queens eggs before again probably you
just don't have enough but they played
93 and what I would say about positions
like this is that okay objectively
you're probably losing because you're
done in exchange but when your opponent
does not have open files being down in
exchange can be not such a bad thing you
can think about it if the rooks are not
on open files why are they better than
bishops and Knight is there a good
reason
I don't really think so so what I would
say is that again even though you're
down material and maybe would best play
you're still losing because you don't
have tons of compensation your life's
not so bad your opponent didn't didn't
take all your pawns which is always nice
and now your pawns are actually nice and
expanded so you know if you ever get
some threats going you're far advanced
pawns will really serve you well so what
I'd recommend is trying to activate your
pieces keep the pressure on and most
importantly do not open files
the second file is open for the rooks
and they start trading and infiltrating
that's when their power really shows if
you can keep the position as close as
possible you're going to have a great
shot at saving this game so you play g6
trying to keep an eye on this night I
don't think this night hop was anything
to worry about too much but it's an
understandable move your opponent plays
Queen f3
so you mentioned d5 as a possible move
it's kind of interesting because
although it shuts down your bishop it
also shuts down this bishop but this
ship g7 I don't think is anything
terrible although I would have strongly
considered 97 if I were you with the
idea of coming into e5 perhaps and
trying to target palms okay Bishop g7 is
playable Queen e2 I'm with you that
White's making aimless Queen moves I
agree with you completely but again this
is something that's very common it's not
easy to play with rooks when you have no
files and I'd say from a practical point
of view people play these positions so
badly because they don't know what to do
and you end up moving back and forth yes
what a computer when this is white
almost for sure but for our human being
I don't think it's so easy you mention
that it takes a safe Square from the
night away hmm also true I mean I don't
like putting that on g3 to begin with
but um I think the bigger problem is
just White's wasting time
I don't agree this is a question mark
where they move but it's certainly not
the best so you take on d3 so I'm sure
you could answer this by now if you've
been listening to me and not falling
asleep but why is this probably not a
good move it opens up the bishop is one
reason but I think there's a more
important reason it opens a file when
you're dealing when you're fighting
against rooks keep those files closed
and this is true regardless of how the
pieces work if you have two pieces
against the rook and two pawns keep the
files closed if you're down in exchange
keep those files closed if you have
Queen against two rooks make it so that
the rooks do not get to work together on
a file
that is how you end up in trouble so
this move I really dislike so the
question is what's better you mentioned
h5 and it gains a tempo because white
has to avoid h4 h4 is a little bit risky
sometimes but I definitely think it's a
possibility another reason I like this
move which you don't mention is let's
say white plays f4 what potential move
do you have now
aha and maybe the night lands on e3
and then your could be in good shape
occasionally you might even think about
takes and rook see - I know you open the
file which is against my rules but if
you get 93 rook c2 you might be able to
live with that and you have lots of
counter play here I like this move h5
it's not the only good move you could
probably come up with some other
improvements but I like this h5 move a
lot again largely because this Knight g4
move hinders white trying to open things
up and go after your king so I really
like this approach but after takes
you're going to have our time because
again you created a file so you're
trying to open lines for the bishop pair
the problem is that white bishops also
open and you're going to have a hard
time doing this once the rooks come to
the center so white captured you took
with the knight so you're hoping having
hopes and dreams of night at 4 I'm
assuming and your opponent eliminated it
now this is kind of an interesting
decision what do you guys think of
Bishop takes Knight as a move and why is
that
I agree with you in principle because
yes the bishop pair can still be strong
and you know the having this bishop on a
- is certainly not a bad piece however
there's another rule which I want you
guys to remember which is that you want
to keep things as simple as possible
when you're out material often what that
means is that maybe you have a good
piece but your opponent this night can
be super dangerous imagine the night
comes f4 right that's going to be a
nasty piece so I actually don't hate
this move
I'm not saying I'd play it for sure the
person who I would look at to be
perfectly honest it's just developing my
rook I'm a simple man with simple tastes
I want to trade off the rooks and blacks
move to the rook we can call this move
certainly not bad I would hope and if
you try to play Knight f4 first of all
now I've taken your Bishop s to go and
if you take now and try this I have the
very nasty Queen e8 check and you
probably are not happy with how your
life has turned out at this point if
King goes here for example the very
simplest by my opinion it's maybe to
just take with the Queen but now you're
threatening the knight as well as Queen
g8 makes this would be hard to recover
from so I like the move rook c1 and
maybe take next move if you really feel
so inclined but I don't hate the move
takes and the reason why is because
black have fewer pieces to threaten you
with this Bishop can't really threaten
you right it's hitting this pawn on d4
just not doing much this Bishop can
definitely threaten you this Knight can
threaten you
obviously the Queen has ideas but when
you eliminate pieces that can threaten
you when you're up material oftentimes
the wind becomes easier because you have
to deal with fewer threats it's as
simple as that so I don't actually hate
this Bishop takes d5 and for sure white
should be winning in a position like
this you play rook c5 and you mentioned
trying to retain control of the C file I
understand
and this temptation but there's a little
bit of flawed logic here and I'm
wondering if someone in our audience can
enlighten us indeed and this is I'd say
the major problem with your idea John
that when your opponent has an extra
look for whatever reason whether it's
two pieces for a rook whether it's an
exchange down if your opponent has that
extra rook you can never take the file
almost ever the exception would be maybe
if the bishop could land on h6 but
there's no time for that so as long as
so queen e7 was played which is a good
move but let's even say white surrenders
the file and this is just a common thing
I'm not saying these are the best moves
in this position but I'm just trying to
illustrate a point now I simply play
Queen d2 how are you going to hold on to
this file you can't because I can play
rook c1 now do I necessarily need this
file to win the game not really but just
to illustrate it you can never ever
claim the file unless your bishop can
control the square the rook can go to or
there's some extraordinary circumstance
but when you have one fewer rook than
your opponent hate to sit your the files
are there's nothing you can do about it
unless you manage with your two bishops
to control every square on a file that's
your only chance now when you're dealing
with a situation like this where you're
down in exchange and you have a
situation where you can either trade
rooks or keep rooks on the board
regardless of whether you're down
material or not let's say you have two
pawns for the exchange even so you're
not it's not a question of oh you don't
want to simplify in a loss position
where you're down material do you want
to trade rooks when you have one fewer
exchange or you have more minor pieces
than your opponent I heard a whispered
no any particular reason
there's going to wait for ten minutes
masky the main reason is just that and
you're correct you want to keep rooks on
the board and the main reason is that
when you have minor pieces they work out
very well in conjunction with rooks so
even if you have two pieces for the rook
keeping a rook on the board is almost
always a good thing to do now there are
exceptions to all these rules as I
mentioned in my students and chess when
I tell you a rule it's usually true
between 60 and 80 percent of the time
almost never is it true above 90 now do
you want to give up your queen for a
night this is an example where it's
above 90 but most general rules in chess
there are exceptions but I would say the
rule where if you have more minor pieces
than your opponent or are down in
exchange or in a situation like this
because remember if you're down in
exchange you have an extra minor piece
something to look forward to right it's
why being down in exchange is not nearly
so bad as being down a whole piece
because there you're just down a piece
you have nothing more than your opponent
does but when you have more minor pieces
than your opponent I'd say at least 80%
of the time you want to keep rooks on
the board the exception would be that if
you're just getting check mated somehow
or if you're simplifying into an easily
won position obviously there are
exceptions but for the most part keep
that rook on the board I would play
Brooke d8 here even if it means somehow
you get viciously checkmate it I don't
see how it's going to happen but I would
say that keeping the rook on the board
will give you more chances for counter
play and more chances for white to
blunder and it's not just because you're
refusing to trade when you're down
material it's because the rook and the
two bishops interact well if you give
away your rook it's hard for the two
bishops by themselves to generate lots
of threats even with the assistance of
the Queen you keep your rook on the
board eventually you try to maybe
maneuver it to attack stuff you'll have
much better chances to trick white or at
the very least create kind of plan so
rook c5 it's not about the file I just
don't like it because you trade rooks
still not to mention Queen e7 kind of an
annoying move so you play Bishop f8
white plays Queen e8 and now you're
pinned up the Knights coming to e4 I
would say things are looking grim you
played Bishop c6 white plays Queen e1
which to me is a wholly mysterious move
queen c8 you mentioned is the possible
move obviously there's this discovery
you have to be careful of but I'm
assuming that rook takes c5 just kind of
end that a bit so Queen C it's probably
a really nice move but even if you
didn't want to calculate too much even
going back to eath two's makes more
sense than e1 Queen e1 is just very
bizarre to me but yeah as you mentioned
Queen CA it's probably a better move so
you played Bishop d7 you're struggling
to find a plan the main reason you're
struggling is because you have a lost
position when your position is bad
there's not that much you can do you
don't have that many plans oftentimes
you're just trying to glue your position
together but again I'd say especially at
the club level if you just keep the
position complex if you avoid blundering
if you keep an eye on what your opponent
wants to do you'll have at least one
chance to maybe get back in the game I
don't like your Bishop d7 move John
because you're taking your bishop off
the potentially dangerous diagonal your
Bishop on d7 is never going to serve the
same purpose of the bishop here at least
make white play f3 which may be weakened
this square for your bishop or play 94
which you can then kick with the bishop
here I don't know I mean I would think
about moves like rook g5 yes the rooks
really weird here spend a few minutes
laughing at it however it at least makes
white sync maybe do I play 94 but then I
have to watch out for rookie 5 pinning
my knight in some positions not here I
should point out but say I even just
come back here again it's like the
knight blocks the Queen the bishop
blocks the rook
that's one move to consider I just don't
want to trade off the rook is my main
logic but even if you do trade off the
rook at least play back here and keep
the bishop on the good diagonal moves
like Queen d7 you can think about
immediately trying to provoke a pawn
move and again the only reason you
provoke f3 is to maybe one day in your
dreams perhaps get a bishop here which
would at least provide you with counter
play but again you got to be looking for
these types of moves 94 and hear you
play rook c6 again kind of tough to make
recommendations but I agree pinning
the night's better Knight f6 check here
does not work because of the Queen can
capture and again maybe you have some
practical chances but I like keeping the
rooks
on the board that does not change once
the rooks come off you're going to have
our time unfortunately your Queen and
pawn are also attacked I realize this
pawn defended which I should have seen
that's right ah it's been a long day so
Queen b6 would have been a better move
and again this is just a very simple
case of when you're down material don't
op trade keep Queens on the board keep
things interesting the only exception is
if you're about to get mated you're
allowed to trade Queens if you have
pawns back in Queen trade the Queen's
when you're in a situation like this
where there's an open file and if you
trade Queens you're just going to end up
in a lost ending do not do it
keep those Queens on the board give
yourself chances to save the game after
Queen b6 you still have plenty of
chances after takes on c1 the chances of
saving this position are minimal mainly
because you don't have dangerous pawns
it'd be one thing if you add like a
weakness here to work with or could take
this guy but as I see it you're just
down the exchange and here you collapse
but and here's something else I would
say that when your position is bad
collapsing is really easy to do most
games are not lost by someone out
playing their opponent indefinitely
they're lost by collapse what I mean is
that your position gets bad until you
just can't defend it anymore until you
make an error human beings are not
computers computers you have to outplay
them til the end of time they're never
going to blunder human beings they get
under pressure what happens is you get a
bad position you get a worse position
and you just can't find moves that are
good and guess what if you can't find a
good move you're going to find a bad one
and that's kind of what happened to hear
it I think so
you were very critical of yourself for
missing Brooke c7 and I have to be
honest
Brooke c7 is the first move that comes
to mind regardless of where you put your
Bishop because I want a penetrate of my
rook so missing this move is not a good
thing that being said I totally
understand missing blundering here
because your position is just not good
and again when your positions bad
blundering is very easy to do if you're
asking me what I do I don't have any
great answers for you negative six check
is the biggest threat so I would try to
deal with that maybe I'd played this
should be six you mentioned Bishop f5
which is also fine
but my hope at least let's say black
plays rook here I don't know this is a
good move or not but just to give you an
example I might try before now my goal
is very simple I just want to trade off
some pawns or at the very least maybe
get a position where I can try to
threaten you with this pawn someday
maybe I'll try Bishop e3 and eventually
try to go after this again I don't think
it can really happen but these are my
hopes these are my dreams etc because if
I can trade off some pawns I might at
least have some shot if you can
eliminate all these pawns maybe you can
draw the game against an opponent who
doesn't know how to win and guess what
at the club level people are not
technical endgame wizards they will fail
to win these positions a lot but again I
would say that it's such a difficult
position that not blundering here is an
extremely tough task do I recommend you
know being more careful looking at moves
like rook g7 looking at moves like
Knight f6 absolutely but you can't be
too critical of yourself for blundering
these positions simply because it's so
easy to do even very strong players even
top grandmasters in the world if their
position becomes bad enough they will
blunder it's just a matter of when and
it's only the very top players who
really are able to defend awful
positions with perfection or close to
perfection as humanly possible I should
say karyakin is one amazing defender but
guess what when he was in trouble
against Magnus in that last game when he
had a bad position he collapsed collapse
happened for everyone - absolutely
everyone a lot of the ways you try to
win a chess game is you don't
necessarily just outplay your opponent
you put enough pressure on them until
they can't play a good move anymore and
that's kind of what does it so after you
blunder this I don't think there's too
much to go over and now resigning is a
pretty safe thing to do in a position
like this
maybe if you're playing a complete
beginner who barely knows how to move
you can continue to play on but against
most strong chess players I would say
this is not good so again I wouldn't be
too harsh on yourself for this game John
you made very understand all those
mistakes that most Club players have
made at one point or another and even
tournament players can do the same thing
but what I remember is first of all
don't trust your opponent too much they
hang a knight in the opening take it do
not be so kind as you were in this game
the other thing is to remember pieces
remember this dish upon a to make sure
you're not opening up that piece for
later in the game make sure you're
keeping track of these moves also as far
as the giving up the exchange goes we
can go back to that one moment just this
was not a matter of a tactical thing you
miss Knight g6 that can happen to anyone
but you panicked or something went wrong
in your calculations and you didn't see
that you could simply save your room and
I'd say that this is one of those
moments where slightly clearer thinking
after missing a couple moves can save
you a lot of trouble in your games
because you really had no reason to lose
this game despite the fact your opponent
was higher raised in any case I thank
you for submitting your game I hope that
you learned some stuff from it as well
as perhaps a couple people in audience
and I hope that you do better in your
next game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]